This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. With a pandemic receding, I'm excited to get back out into the world, but I'm really not excited about getting back on an airplane. The seats are too small, I hate waiting in line, and in my opinion, people who lean back in their airplane seats are history's greatest monsters. Every year, fights break out between people who lean back on airplanes and people who get their knees smushed. A man apparently got upset when the woman in front of him suddenly reclined her seat.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。随着疫情逐渐消退，我很高兴能重新回到外面的世界，但我真的对再次坐飞机感到兴奋不起来。座位太小了，我讨厌排队，而且在我看来，在飞机座椅上把椅背往后调的人是历史上最大的恶魔。每年，在飞机上把椅背往后调的人和膝盖被挤扁的人之间都会爆发冲突。据报道，一个男的因为前面的女人突然把座椅往后调而感到很不爽。
That's when the man allegedly reached forward and started choking the other passenger. So the woman stood up and threw a cup of water in his face. A man started punching her seat repeatedly as the video shows. Sometimes planes have to be grounded because of these fights, and the reason for these fights is confusion. Think about it. Both people paid for a seat on the airplane, but who owns the space behind the seat back? The Sanctuary's battling stories, The person who's sitting in front,
就在那时，那名男子据称伸出手开始掐住另一名乘客的脖子。于是那名女子站起来，把一杯水泼到了他脸上。视频显示，一名男子开始多次击打她的座位。有时飞机不得不因为这些争吵而停飞，而这些争吵的原因是混乱。仔细想想。两个人都为飞机上的座位付了钱，但谁拥有座椅靠背后面的空间呢？庇护所交织的故事，坐在前面的人，
they've got the button and they're basically saying, look, it's a task to something I own. If I can lean back into it, it's mine. The person in the back says, wait a minute. Possession, I'm possessing a space, I'm using it for my knees, I'm using it for my laptop. And when you lean your seat back into my space, that's trespass.
他们手里有按钮，基本上是在说，听着，这是我拥有的东西的一部分。如果我能向后靠进去，那就是我的。后面的人则说，等一下。占有，我占有了一个空间，我用它来放我的膝盖，我用它来放我的笔记本电脑。而当你把座椅向后靠进我的空间时，这就是侵占。
And that ambiguity actually is deliberate. Airlines are doing that in order to be able to sell that same space twice. That's Jim Sultzman and Michael Heller, their law professors and authors of a new book called Mine, How the Hidden Rules of Ownership Control Our Lives. We do a lot of public speaking about this and we'll pull the audience. And almost every single time he asks is there right to recline or right to defend your knees and it's 50-50. Really? And people look at each other with incredulity. How can you possibly think differently? Ownership might seem really clear-cut. Like if you own a house or a car, you own it. And
这种模糊性其实是刻意为之的。航空公司这么做是为了能够把同一个空间卖两次。那是吉姆·萨尔茨曼和迈克尔·海勒，他们是法学教授，也是一本名为《我的：所有权的隐藏规则如何掌控我们的生活》的新书的作者。我们经常就此进行公开演讲，我们会做观众调查。几乎每一次，当他问是否存在靠后放松的权利或捍卫膝盖的权利时，结果都是五五开。真的吗？人们带着难以置信的表情看着彼此。你怎么可能持有完全不同的观点？所有权看起来可能非常明确。就像如果你拥有一栋房子或一辆车，你就是拥有它。而且
the story. But Jim and Michael write about how the rules of ownership are a lot more complicated than we think. Ownership rules are actually designed. Sometimes they're designed for the good of humanity, like keeping patent protection short for vaccines or even waving them completely. But more often, ownership rules can be designed for nefarious purposes, like the rules around airplane seats. Here's Michael Heller.
这个故事。但吉姆和迈克尔在书中写道，所有权的规则远比我们想象的要复杂得多。所有权规则其实是人为设计的。有时它们的设立是为了人类的福祇，比如缩短疫苗的专利保护期，甚至完全豁免。但更常见的是，所有权规则的设计可能是出于邪恶的目的，比如围绕飞机座椅的规则。迈克尔·海勒在这里为您讲述。
Ownership is ambiguous way more often than people realize. Whose wedge of space is that? Is it mine? Is it yours? We don't know. That is one of the most powerful advanced tools of ownership design, is being ambiguous deliberately in order to profit from the ambiguity.
所有权变得模糊的频率远超人们的认知。那是谁的那片空间？是我的吗？是你的吗？我们不知道。这是所有权设计中最强大的高级工具之一，即故意保持模糊，以便从这种模糊性中获利。
Today, we're going to talk with Jim and Michael about how the rules of ownership are created and why bad ones can influence everything from baseball to solar panels to farmland in the American South. I mean this fight on a plane is really extreme about something that's so little in a lot of ways, you know, like a few inches of space. But your book is full of these types of stories. Like I call it an academic bar fight book, like completely joyful to read, but like it's a thing to start and settle fights
今天，我们将与吉姆和迈克尔一起探讨所有权规则是如何制定的，以及为什么糟糕的规则会影响从棒球、太阳能电池板到美国南部农田的方方面面。我的意思是，飞机上的这场争执真的很极端，争夺的在很多方面其实是非常小的东西，你知道，比如几英寸的空间。但你们的书里充满了这类故事。就像我称之为一本学术酒吧斗殴书，读起来非常开心，但它是一本用来挑起和解决争执的书
because there's all these cases where everyone thinks they're right. And so why are ownership questions so complicated? Well, they're complicated in some way. They're actually quite simple. Like, you go to a playground and then you hear kids, you know, I mean, mine, mine, mine. They both have their hand on the shovel. It's just sound, it's like the mine, mine, on the airplane seat. And it turns out that all these battles are based on the same simple stories
因为这里有各种各样的案例，每个人都认为自己是对的。那么，为什么所有权问题会如此复杂呢？嗯，它们在某些方面很复杂。其实它们相当简单。比如，你去游乐场，然后你会听到孩子们，你知道的，我的，我的，我的。他们俩的手都放在铁锹上。这只是声音，就像飞机座位上的“我的，我的”一样。事实证明，所有这些争端都基于相同的简单故事
that kids learn and use effectively in the playground. Yeah, in your book you talk about how there are these six stories that we use to justify ownership. So what are they? Well, we have the kids in the playground. Mine. I'm first, first in time. Mine. I'm holding on to it. Possession is 910 to the law. You have a little button on the airplane. It's mine because it's attached to something mine. That's three of the six. The fourth one is it's mine because I worked for it. That's our intuition behind copyrights and patents and intellectual property. You reap what you sow. That's the fourth is labor. The fifth is it's mine because it comes from my body, our DNA. And the last one is family. It's mine because I'm in the family.
孩子们在游乐场里学习并有效地运用这些故事。是的，在你们的书里，你们谈到了我们用来证明所有权合理性的这六个故事。那么它们是什么呢？好吧，我们有游乐场里的孩子们。我的。我先来，先到先得。我的。我抓着它不放。占有占了法律的十分之九。你在飞机上有个小按钮。它是我的，因为它附着在我拥有的东西上。这是六个中的三个。第四个是它属于我，因为我为此付出了劳动。这就是我们对版权、专利和知识产权的直觉。一分耕耘，一分收获。第四个是劳动。第五个是它属于我，因为它来自我的身体，我们的DNA。最后一个是家庭。它是我的，因为我属于这个家庭。
Birth and death, marriage and divorce. That's the great moment when property is on the move. And that's it. All ownership conflict. Everything that we fight about, you know, when someone cuts in front of a line at Disney, or who gets the coffee first at Starbucks, you know, whether you can get your parking space back at the end of the day, when you get out from a snowstorm, all of that, all of it, is based on just those same six stories. Yeah. Yeah.
生老病死，结婚离婚。那是财产流转的伟大时刻。就是这样。所有的所有权冲突。我们争论的一切，你知道的，当有人在迪士尼插队时，或者在星巴克谁先买到咖啡，你知道的，当你在一场暴风雪后，一天结束时是否能找回你的停车位，所有这一切，所有的一切，都只是基于那同样的六个故事。是的。是的。
You use this phrase possession is 910th of the law. I have never really understood this phrase. Like as an editor, I have cut it out of scripts because I don't really understand it. And I don't know if anyone really understands it. What does it mean? It actually traces back to an ancient, ancient woman, the oldest legal code still known is the code of Hamunirabias from 4,000 years ago.
你们用了“占有占了法律的十分之九”这个短语。我从来没有真正理解过这个短语。作为一个编辑，我曾把它从文稿中删掉，因为我真的不太懂。而且我也不知道是不是真的有人懂。它到底是什么意思？它实际上可以追溯到一个极其古老的女性，目前已知的最古老的法典是4000年前的汉谟拉比法典。
And back in that code, if somebody else was on your land and they farmed it for a couple of years, even though it was your land, it became their land. So possession, it turned out, was 9th 10th of a law. Your ownership mattered, but if you didn't defend it against a possessor who was adverse to you, who was farming it against your wishes,
在那部法典中，如果其他人在你的土地上耕种了几年，即使那是你的土地，它也会变成他们的土地。因此事实证明，占有占了法律的十分之九。你的所有权很重要，但如果你不防范一个对立的占有者，一个违背你的意愿在那里耕种的人，
they actually became the owner. And that law of adverse possession from 4,000 years ago is still the law today. It blows the minds of our students. When they find out, it'll turn out to say, Hey, in my backyard, my neighbor mows the lawn. Does that mean that they're going to own the land? Yeah, eventually. Or the fence is not quite in the right place. Or we cut through a neighbor's backyard to get to the beach. All of that reality of who's actually possessing
他们实际上就成为了所有者。4000年前的这种时效占有法在今天依然是法律。这让我们的学生感到大开眼界。当他们发现这一点时，结果会变成，嘿，在我的后院，我的邻居在修剪草坪。这是否意味着他们将拥有这片土地？是的，最终会这样。或者栅栏的位置不太对。或者我们穿过邻居的后院去海滩。所有关于谁在实际占有
and using land, that becomes the law. Part of possession's non-tense of law is actually a very deep-seated psychological fact to being human. Psychologists call it the endowment effect. When you physically possess something, it becomes more valuable to you. So imagine, for example, you're at a supermarket and you've filled up your shopping cart and Michael comes along and says, eggs, perfect. I was looking for that. Oh, you've got cheese too. I'll take that too. How would
和使用土地的现实，都变成了法律。占有占法律十分之九的一部分，实际上是人类根深蒂固的心理事实。心理学家称之为“禀赋效应”。当你物理上占有某样东西时，它对你来说就变得更有价值了。所以想象一下，比如你在超市里，你装满了购物车，迈克尔走过来，说：鸡蛋，太完美了。我正找这个呢。哦，你还有奶酪？我也要了。你会怎么
you react? Yeah, I would feel like he was stealing from me because it was in my cart, but I do not own it because I did not buy it. Yeah. So where's it coming from? Right? There's nothing more fundamental about ownership than realizing that ownership is just a storytelling battle. It's just my story of first versus your story of labor, or my story of possession versus your story of attachment. That is all ownership is, it's those competing stories. So I, for example, teach at Columbia Law School. And there's a campus, there's open people just walk across it. Once a year in a quiet Sunday morning, they lock all the gates. Not because they're doing maintenance, but just to say, this is ours,
反应？是的，我会觉得他在偷我的东西，因为它在我的购物车里，但我并不拥有它，因为我没有买它。是的。所以这到底是哪里来的？对吧？关于所有权，没有什么比意识到所有权只是一场讲故事的争夺更根本的了。这只是我的“先来后到”的故事与你的“劳动”的故事的对决，或者是我的“占有”的故事与你的“附属”的故事的对决。所有权就是这么回事，它们就是这些相互竞争的故事。比如，我在哥伦比亚法学院教书。那里有一个校园，是开放的，人们可以直接穿过去。一年中的某一天，在一个安静的星期天早晨，他们会锁上所有的门。不是因为他们在进行维护，而只是为了表明，这是我们的，
and you can't make a claim, you the public can't make a claim, you don't eventually own it by possession, because we can keep you out and we do it once a year. As you walk around New York City, you see these little plaques in the sidewalk, let's say permission to grant revocable at any time. And what the buildings are doing there is they're trying to keep that sidewalk private. Even though other people are walking on it, they don't make a claim to it because they're
你们不能提出索赔，你们公众不能提出索赔，你们不会最终通过占有而拥有它，因为我们可以把你们挡在外面，而且我们每年都这样做。当你走在纽约街头时，你会看到人行道上有这样的小牌子，上面写着“特许权随时可撤销”。而这些建筑在做的是，它们试图保持这个人行道的私密性。尽管其他人也在上面行走，但他们并没有对其提出所有权主张，因为他们
there by permission with that little plaque. It's not adverse. It doesn't eventually lead to ownership. So you may not think about this in your day-to-day life, but the life of who owns what is not static is always a choice. So an example from a book of confusing ownership design is about baseballs. Who owns a baseball when it is hit into the stands in a game? So tell me this story about Barry Bond's
是在获得许可的情况下通过那块小牌子来到这里的。这不是对抗性的。它最终不会导致所有权。所以你可能在日常生活中不会去想这个，但谁拥有什么的生命周期并不是静止的，它永远是一种选择。因此，书中一个关于混乱所有权设计的例子是关于棒球的。当一个棒球在比赛中被击入观众席时，谁拥有这个球？所以，请讲讲巴里·邦兹的
home run ball. So as many of your listeners who recall, Barry Bond's had this incredibly media-fueled frenzy about breaking the single season record for home runs. There was a guy named Popov, and he was not just a student of baseball. He really studied where Bond's home runs had landed, and so he bought a seat at baseball. He really, you know, studied where bonds, homeruns, had landed,
这记本垒打球的故事。正如你们的许多听众所回忆的那样，巴里·邦兹打破单季本垒打纪录这件事引发了媒体疯狂的炒作。有一个叫波波夫的家伙，他不仅仅是一个棒球迷。他认真研究了邦兹的本垒打落点，因此他在棒球场买了个座位。他真的，你知道的，研究了邦兹本垒打落下的地点，
and so he bought a seat at Pactel Stadium, and he brought his baseball glove with him for the day that he hoped bonds would break the record. And in fact, he was in the exact right place. Bond cracks the ball. There's a high pride! Deep in the right center field to the big part of the rock park, number 70. That was out of the park, and he catches the ball for an instant and then he's mugged. The ball is jarred loose and this guy, Hayashi, who just happened to, you know, be there because it would be fun to go to a game, walks out of the melee with a ball that some people are saying is worth a million dollars. This being the great country of America, pop up Susan, right?
于是在邦兹有望打破纪录的那天，他带着棒球棒球手套买下了帕克特球场的座位。事实上，他当时就在绝对正确的位置。邦兹击中了球！高高飞起！直奔罗克公园大号右中外野深处，第70号。球飞出了球场，他用手套接住了球不到一瞬间，然后他就被群殴了。球被撞落了，而这个恰巧因为觉得去看比赛会很有趣而来到那里的家伙——林，从混战中走了出来，手里拿着那个被一些人认为价值百万美元的球。作为一个伟大的美利坚合众国，波波夫起诉了，对吧？
So, you know, we're talking about possession and Zontet, the law doesn't mean he owns the ball. This being the great country of America, pop-up Susan. Right? So, you know, we're talking about possession on 10th of the law. Doesn't mean he owns the ball. And so the question, it goes to court. And the judge asks, well, who should own the ball? And it's not obvious, right? So you could say for pop-up, well, it's labor, right? He did the work to figure out where to stand.
所以，你知道，我们在谈论占有与法律的十分之九，这并不意味着他拥有这个球。作为一个伟大的美利坚合众国，波波夫起诉了。对吧？所以，你知道，我们在谈论占有占法律的十分之九。这并不意味着他拥有这个球。所以这个问题闹上了法庭。法官问，那么谁应该拥有这个球呢？这并不显而易见，对吧？所以你可以为波波夫辩护说，这是劳动，对吧？他做了功课去算出该站在哪里。
It's first possession. He actually had the ball for a moment, then it was dislodged. Hayashi is current possession, so which story should win? Well, it's not just that, right? It's also a question of how do you want to design the rule to shape behavior, right? So if we want to protect future game goers, I mean, it turns out a lot of folks are injured with foul balls and other balls. Maybe you want to encourage the pop-ups of the world to actually go out there, you know, with the gloves to protect us. And so the rule is as soon as you've got initial possession, even
这是首次占有。他实际上拿到过这个球一会儿，然后它被撞掉了。林是当前的占有者，所以哪个故事应该获胜？嗯，不仅如此，对吧？这还涉及到如何设计规则来塑造行为的问题，对吧？如果我们想保护未来的观众，我的意思是，事实证明很多人被界外球和其他球击伤。也许你想鼓励像波波夫这样的人真的带着手套去外面保护我们。所以规则是，一旦你最初拥有了它，即使
it was Jarlus, it's yours. Or we say, look, let's go to custom. You know, the fact is that when you go to a ball game, whoever ends up with a ball, they own it. It's not uniform, right? You don't see fans going home from a football game with a football. You don't see fans going home from a soccer game with a soccer ball. The custom in those sports is you return the ball. And then of course, there's the great question, well, why doesn't Bond own it? Right. Of course, but he was actually, he's the one person who probably shouldn't own it, because he was trying to get the thing out of the stadium. So the judge ultimately decided to auction the ball and split the proceeds between the two men. Was that a good
它被撞落了，它也是你的。或者我们说，看，让我们遵循习俗。事实是，当你去看球赛时，最后拿到球的人，球就归他们所有。这并不统一，对吧？你不会看到球迷看完橄榄球赛带着橄榄球回家。你不会看到球迷看完足球赛带着足球回家。这些运动中的习俗是你必须把球还回去。然后当然，还有一个很大的问题，为什么邦兹不拥有它？对吧。当然，但他实际上是唯一一个最不应该拥有它的人，因为他当时正试图把这东西打出球场。所以法官最终决定拍卖这个球，并将收益平分给这两个人。这是一个好
outcome? It's like there was Solomon's revenge here, you know, a perfectly plausible solution was trying to be fair as between Papa and Hayashi. You can always decide, and ownership is never a given. There's no answer what you have to do. Gemini basically want not to get hit by foul balls. Like I'm more likely to get hit than to catch one. So I really think the rule should have been Papa. So a lot of ownership rules do is I tell you how to behave in the world.
结果吗？这就像这里有所罗门王的裁决一样，你知道，一个看似完全合理的解决方案是在波波夫和林之间试图做到公平。你随时可以做出决定，所有权从来都不是天经地义的。对于你必须做什么并没有标准答案。吉姆和我基本上不想被界外球击中。就像我挨打的可能性比接住一个球的可能性更大。所以我真的认为规则应该是波波夫赢。因此，许多所有权规则所做的事情就是告诉你如何在世界上表现。
So one of our basic points, if I get across to our students, to our readers, is that ownership works like one of the great invisible remote controls of your life. All these ownership rules are steering you this way in that to get you to do what somebody else wants. And what I want with the baseball is somebody else to watch out over me, and that's pop-off. This is an example of how poor ownership design can end up in court, but there are some examples of good ownership design leading to better outcomes, and I'm thinking in particular of the show, the Deadliest Catch. The vast, bearing sea.
所以我们的基本观点之一，如果我要传达给我们的学生、我们的读者，那就是所有权就像你生活中的一个伟大的无形遥控器。所有这些所有权规则都在引导你这样或那样做，让你去做别人想让你做的事。而我对棒球的诉求是有人替我放哨，那就是波波夫。这是一个关于糟糕的所有权设计如何最终闹上法庭的例子，但也有一些好的所有权设计带来更好结果的例子，我特别想到了《致命捕捞》这个节目。广袤的白令海。
Over a million square miles of the world's most violent and unpredictable waters at all of the deadliest catch Alaskan crab. And the first season is extremely harrowing because it's a derby style system and that system was really dangerous, but they changed the system in the later seasons and I have to admit the deadliest catch became a lot more boring, but it was more safe, it was better in every way. It just was made for boring TV. Can you describe the new ownership system and how that worked? Sure. So as you describe, the rule had been first come first served. So there was a quota that was set,
拥有超过一百万平方英里世界上最狂暴、最变幻莫测的水域，这一切都孕育了最致命的捕捞——阿拉斯加蟹。第一季极其惊心动魄，因为采用的是德比式的捕捞系统，这个系统非常危险，但在后来的几季中他们改变了这个系统，我必须承认，《致命捕捞》变得无聊多了，但它更安全了，在各方面都更好了。它只是变得不适合做刺激的电视节目了。你能描述一下新的所有权系统及其运作方式吗？当然。正如你所描述的，以前的规则是先到先得。所以设定了一个配额，
season started, and basically this season ended when the quota 10 tons, 20 tons, whatever had been caught. And this led to what you call derby fishing, and it was incredibly dangerous because if the weather's ended when the quota 10 tons, 20 tons, whatever had been caught. And this led to what you call derby fishing, and it was incredibly dangerous, because if the weather's terrible, you go out, because if you don't go out and someone else goes out, this is the over before you get a chance. It was actually more dangerous statistically
捕捞季开始，基本上当捕捞量达到配额——10吨、20吨或无论多少时，这一季就结束了。这就导致了你们所说的德比式捕捞，这极其危险，因为如果天气当捕捞量达到配额——10吨、20吨或无论多少时，这一季就结束了。这就导致了你们所说的德比式捕捞，这极其危险，因为如果天气糟糕，你也得出海，因为如果你不出海而别人出海了，在你得到机会之前，这一切就都结束了。在阿拉斯加白令海的帝王蟹船上工作，在统计学上甚至比在这一时期的伊拉克执行步兵巡逻任务
to work on a king crab boat in the Bering Sea, Aflaska, than to be on foot patrol in Iraq during this period. Wow. Wow. It changed because of some very clever ownership engineers in Iceland of all places. And they said, wait a minute, let's look at how the catch is owned. What they said is, what if we take that season's catch and we divide it up in front, right? At the start of the season. And so, you know, Roman, you caught three tons of fish last year, you get what's called an allowance,
还要危险。哇。哇。这一切的改变要归功于冰岛——偏偏是在冰岛——一些非常聪明的产权工程师。他们说，等一下，让我们看看捕捞权是如何拥有的。他们的意思是，如果我们把那个捕捞季的渔获量预先划分好呢？在捕捞季开始的时候。所以，你知道的，罗曼，你去年捕了三吨鱼，你得到了所谓的配额，
right? You basically get a permission to catch three tons this year, Michael only fished one ton, so he gets one ton. When the weather's bad, you stay in port. When the price is low, you stay in port. And as a result, very quickly, as you said, deaths went down, profits went
你基本上获得了今年捕捞三吨的许可，迈克尔只捕了一吨，所以他得到一吨。当天气恶劣时，你留在港口。当价格低迷时，你留在港口。结果，正如你所说，非常快地，死亡人数下降了，利润上升了
up. And in fact, no one's died for years in this fishery. You know, the problem is you can't call the show the not so deadly catch, right? Who's going to watch that? And so the real, the real loser and all this has been the editors of the deadliest catch because they've got to manufacture these terribly dangerous looking situations, but this idea called catch shares really has caught on around the world. And that's how the best fisheries are now managed. You read about how technology changes ownership rules and how it can make the rules more complicated.
事实上，这个渔业已经多年没有人死亡了。你知道，问题在于你不能把这个节目叫做《不太致命的捕捞》，对吧？谁会看那个？所以真正的、真正的输家其实是《致命捕捞》的剪辑师，因为他们必须人为制造出这些看起来极其危险的情况，但这种被称为捕捞配额（Catch Shares）的概念确实已经在世界各地流行开来。这也是现在管理最佳渔业的方式。你们在书中探讨了技术如何改变所有权规则，以及它如何使规则变得更加复杂。
An great example of this is how Amazon and Apple sell movies and books online. How has the ownership of books and movies changed because of technology? So there have been some studies done on this and 85% of people, when they buy an e-book or and 85% of people when they buy an e-book or download a movie, actually e-books a better example, they feel as though they have full ownership as though they actually own the hard copy of the book. And that's just not the case. We are streaming a series of ones and zeros. We basically are licensing the access to those ones and zeros. Amazon and Apple can and have taken content back. You look at your iPhone, right? What is your iPhone? What do you own with your iPhone? You own a plastic brick, right? What is value by your iPhone is the operating
这方面的一个绝佳例子是亚马逊和苹果如何在网上销售电影和书籍。技术的介入如何改变了书籍和电影的所有权？所以有一些关于这方面的研究表明，85%的人在购买电子书或当85%的人在购买电子书或下载电影时——其实电子书是更好的例子——他们觉得他们拥有完整的所有权，就像他们真的拥有实体书一样。但事实并非如此。我们只是在流式传输一连串的1和0。我们基本上是在获得访问这些1和0的许可。亚马逊和苹果可以也确实收回过内容。你看看你的iPhone，对吧？你的iPhone是什么？你的iPhone里有什么是你真正拥有的？你拥有的是一块塑料砖，对吧？你的iPhone的真正价值在于操作系统。
system. You don't own that. The data on your phone, you don't own that, right? We are moving sort of it really is an apical shift. We're moving from the tangible idea of ownership, which is basically how we evolved to this non-tangible. The way that Amazon profits from this is that we bring with us our physical tangible notion, this notion of possession. We bring that to our online lives. So when Amazon, when you check out, they have a little shopping cart, and they have a little buy now button.
你不拥有那个。你手机上的数据，你也不拥有那个，对吧？我们正在经历某种实质上是根本性的转变。我们正从有形的所有权概念（这是我们的进化方式）转向这种无形的所有权。亚马逊从中获利的方式是，我们将我们有形的、实物的观念，即这种占有的观念带入了网络生活。所以当你在亚马逊结账时，他们有一个购物车，还有一个立即购买按钮。
All of that is very carefully engineered to give you an image of ownership and is not what you're actually getting. Online, the buy now button does not mean what you think it means. I mean, one of the things that forwards the story or changes the story, as you mentioned with Facebook Facebook and is technology itself.
所有这一切都经过非常仔细的设计，给你一种拥有所有权的错觉，而这并不是你实际得到的。在网络上，“立即购买”并不意味着你以为的那个意思。我的意思是，推动这个故事发展或改变这个故事的事情之一，正如你对Facebook所提到的那样，就是技术本身。
It changes the story of ownership quite a bit. And one of the great stories of this ambiguous ownership involves air rights over land, which really took a different turn as soon as airplanes started flying over land. And when original land ownership ideas had no concept of airplanes. Can you talk about this as being kind of the fraught subject of air rights and land ownership? Sure. So this is the story of attachment, right? A landowner knows that they own the surface, but do they own the column of air that goes above the land? Now there's this old Roman law maxim that you own actually from heaven down to hell.
它在相当大程度上改变了所有权的故事。而关于这种模糊所有权的伟大故事之一，就涉及土地上空的航空权。一旦飞机开始在土地上空飞行，航空权就发生了截然不同的转变。而最初的土地所有权理念中根本没有飞机的概念。你能谈谈这作为航空权和土地所有权这个充满争议的主题吗？当然。这就是附属的故事，对吧？土地所有者知道他们拥有地表，但他们拥有土地上方的空气柱吗？现在有一个古老的罗马法格言，即你实际拥听到的从天堂到地狱都属于你。
And so it seems kind of silly now, but in the early age of modern aviation, there actually were trespass suits that were brought against airlines flying over people's backyards. And if you think you own this column of air, well, it is trespass. Now fortunately, courts said, no, no, no, no, no. You only control a certain amount above your house. So that was settled. But it's playing out again right now with drones. So Amazon, UPS, Domino's pizza, they all envision a world where drones are going to take care
所以现在看来这似乎有点傻，但在现代航空的早期，确实有人针对飞越人们后院的航空公司提起过侵占诉讼。如果你认为你拥有这根空气柱，嗯，这就是侵占。幸运的是，法庭裁定，不，不，不，不，不。你只能控制房屋上方的一定高度。所以这个问题算解决了。但现在随着无人机的出现，它正在重新上演。所以亚马逊、UPS、达美乐比萨，他们都在设想这样一个世界：无人机将取代货车来进行配送。
of deliveries instead of cargo trucks. And technically, it's not far away, but there's a problem. And the problem is when a drone flies over your backyard, is it trespassing? We have federal law that dictates how high a drone can fly, but it's silent how low a drone can fly. And at what point is a drone, like an airplane that's 10,000 feet above your property? And at what point is it someone in a UPS uniform jumping over your back fence, you know, and clambering across your yard and jumping out again? This is up for grabs and it's incredibly significant in terms of what delivery services
从技术上讲，这已经不远了，但有一个问题。问题是，当无人机飞过你的后院时，它是在侵占吗？我们有联邦法律规定无人机可以飞多高，但对于无人机可以飞多低却缄口不言。在什么情况下，无人机就像在你的房产上空1万英尺的飞机？又在什么情况下，它就像一个穿着UPS制服的人跳过你的后院栅栏，你知道的，笨拙地穿过你的院子然后又跳出去？这是有争议的，而且对于未来的配送服务来说，这具有极其重大的意义
are going to look like in the near future. Another part of ownership, the air, comes a big issue when we're talking about solar panels. You need access to sunlight for solar panels to work. And there's this really interesting case in Sunnyvale, California evolving solar panels and and redwood trees. Can you describe this story? Yeah, and it's the perfectly named town right, Sunnyvale, right? Where else would you have an argument with over solar panels? There's this sort of little sort of green enclave two neighbors one house has these nice redwood trees that are growing stully and the neighbor puts in solar panels and in time the redwood trees start to shade the solar panels and The guy with the solar panel says hey attachment, right? I have a right to the sun that's powering my solar panels
所有权的另一部分——空气，在我们谈论太阳能电池板时成了一个大问题。太阳能电池板要发挥作用，你需要阳光照射。加利福尼亚州森尼韦尔市有一个非常有趣的案例，涉及太阳能电池板和红木树。你能描述一下这个故事吗？是的，这是一个名字起得绝佳的小镇，对吧，森尼韦尔（阳光谷）？除了那里，你还能在哪里因为太阳能电池板而引发争论呢？这里有一个由两户邻居组成的绿色飞地，其中一户的院子里长着几棵长势喜人的漂亮红木树，而邻居安装了太阳能电池板。随着时间的推移，红木树开始遮挡太阳能电池板。拥有太阳能电池板的那个人说，嘿，按附属原则，
You need to top your trees off and the other saying no, no, no, you know This is attachment basically. I control what happens on my property They what makes it such a great story is it's green versus green right who wins between growing trees and solar And the fact is when you think about this quickly you say well one person's got to win right either you get solar power or you get trees And California they put their thumb on the scale of solar panels quickly you say, well, one person's got to win, right? Either you get solar power or you get trees. In California, they put their thumb on the scale of solar panels and basically said, the trees have to come down. There's this wonderful quote this person says that where the first person ever to be prosecuted for growing redwoods, right? But one of the things we talk about in the book is there are clever ways to design ownership. And so what you could do is you could say,
我有权享受阳光来为我的太阳能电池板供电！你需要把你的树头锯掉。而另一个人说，不，不，不，你知道的，这是附属权。我控制我财产上发生的事情。让这个故事如此精彩的是，这是环保与环保的对决，在生长的树木和太阳能之间，谁会赢？事实上，当你快速思考这个问题时，你会说，好吧，总得有一方获胜吧？要么你获得太阳能，要么你保留树木。在加利福尼亚州，他们把大拇指重重地按在了太阳能电池板这一边，Basically said, the trees have to come down. 这有一句绝妙的名词，这个人说，这是有史以来第一个因为种植红木而被起诉的人，对吧？但我们在书中讨论的事情之一是，存在设计所有权的巧妙方法。所以你可以做的是，
okay, solar panels owner, you can get your solar power, but you've got to compensate your neighbors for lopping off their trees because there's nothing morally wrong. They're not bad people for growing trees. Or similarly, if we say to the tree owners, you can let your trees grow, but you've got to compensate your neighbor
好吧，太阳能电池板的所有者，你可以获得你的太阳能，但你必须补偿你的邻居砍树的损失，因为他们种树并没有在道德上做错什么，他们不是坏人。或者同样地，如果我们对树木所有者说，你可以让你的树木生长，但你必须补偿你的邻居
for the shade that you're casting on the solar panels. Then you change the discussion. In really the solution had to do with the state of California, feeling that solar panel and energy development was more of a priority than growing what redwoods at that moment. I think that's kind of fascinating, like that values are involved, rather than fairness, in ownership is pretty interesting and probably kind of mind blowing. I don't think people think of it that way. It's true.
因为你的树木给太阳能电池板投下的阴影。然后你就改变了讨论的方向。实际上，解决问题的关键在于加利福尼亚州政府认为，在那一刻，太阳能电池板和能源开发比种植红木更具优先权。我认为这挺迷人的，价值观被牵扯进来，而不是仅仅讲究公平，所有权这事儿挺有意思的，而且可能有点颠覆三观。我觉得人们平时不会这么想。确实如此。
And it's turtles all the way down. Like it's true for every own, you know, all day long, it's where you live. That's what you drink. All of those disputes, all of those choices go very quickly to our most fundamental values about what's fair, about what our society to look like. All of that is encoded through ownership. this. So far people fighting over airlines eats in baseball. It can feel like the entire world is encompassed in those fights, but they're pretty small stories. But some of the biggest tensions in our country come from confusing ownership rules, like how Europeans come to America as colonizers,
而且这就像是“大龟驮小龟，层层无尽头”。对于所有的所有权来说都是如此，你知道，整整一天，你住的地方，你喝的水。所有这些争端，所有这些选择，都迅速指向了我们关于什么是公平、我们的社会应该是什么样子的最基本价值观。所有这一切，都是通过所有权编码实现的。因此，到目前为止，人们为飞机座位和棒球争吵不克斯。这可能会让人觉得整个世界都包含在这些争端中，但它们其实是很小的故事。不过，我们国家一些最大的紧张局势源于混乱的所有权规则，比如欧洲人作为殖民者来到美洲，
and they see ownership very, very differently than how indigenous people see it. So could you talk about how ownership affects that type of conflict? The place that you're standing or sitting right now, somebody owns it who bought it from someone else, who bought it from someone else, and that trace is back to conquest. Every piece of land in America traces back to conquest by European settlers of Native Americans. And that's true not just for all land in America, that's true for all land everywhere in the world. But history is a series of conquests and dispositions. Ownership starts anew, the clock starts anew when you have some new regime takeover. So in the U.S., there was a real question early on, which is who owned America?
他们对所有权的看法与原住民对所有权的看法有着天壤之别。所以，你们能谈谈所有权是如何影响这种冲突的吗？你现在站着或坐着的地方，某个人拥有它，他是从另一个人那里买的，那个人又是从另一个人那里买的，而这可以追溯到征服。美洲的每一块土地都可以追溯到欧洲定居者对美洲原住民的征服。不仅美洲的所有土地是这样，世界上所有地方的所有土地都是这样。但历史就是一系列的征服与剥夺。当新的政权接管时，所有权就会重新开始，时钟就会重新拨零。所以在美洲早期有一个真正的问题，那就是谁拥有美洲？
And courts had to figure this out. And the turn to what they decided is that productive labor is what counted. So who was first in America? When the courts were thinking about this in the early 1800s, they said, first is first to cut down trees. First to make New England look like Old England. So for the courts, they defined first to basically privilege a merchant and agricultural economy over a native economy that sort of tread lightly through the soil.
法庭不得不弄清楚这一点。他们最终确定的转向是，有生产力的劳动才算数。所以在美洲谁是第一？18世纪初，当法庭考虑这个问题时，他们说，第一就是第一个砍伐树木的人。第一个让新英格兰看起来像老英格兰的人。因此，对于法院来说，他们对“第一”的定义基本上是赋予商业和农业经济以特权，而将那种在土地上轻轻踩过的原住民经济置于次要地位。
And what that reveals is that these stories who who is first, are themselves always up for grabs. This has always been true, and this is true today, um, and fights them Cuba over who's going to own, you know, Havana, if the government there changes. It was true in Eastern Europe after the Soviets fell. That it's always based at some ultimate level on force and conquest, and what you have is a battle of stories about what and who should be first.
而这所揭示的是，这些关于“谁是第一”的故事，本身总是可以被争夺的。这在过去一直是真的，在今天也依然如此。如果那里的政府发生更迭，古巴人还会为谁将拥有哈瓦那而争吵。苏联解体后的东欧也是如此。它在某种终极层面上总是基于武力和征服，而你所拥有的是一场关于什么以及谁应该是第一的故事的争夺。
One thing we learned from your book is how ownership rules can be arbitrary, and land in America is the most brutal example of that. Something I didn't know is that land ownership in America was actually litigated in court, but of course the courts were enforcing the ownership rules invented by the European colonizers. Well, you know, in the same cases that say, you know, first is the first to make new and little like old The courts also said the you know the courts of the conqueror Determine the boundaries of the conquest. Yeah, so that that is you know, there is an underlying reality Might makes right which underlies
我们从你们的书中学到的一件事是，所有权规则可能是多么武断，而美洲的土地就是其中最残酷的例子。我不知道的一件事是，美洲的土地所有权实际上是在法庭上进行诉讼的，但当然，法院执行的是欧洲殖民者发明的那些所有权规则。嗯，你知道的，在那些宣称“第一个让新英格兰看起来像老英格兰的人就是第一”的同一些案件中，
ownership always. I was also really fascinated by this discussion that you have in the book about how ownership affects black wealth in the country. Could you tell me about some of the issues facing black landowners in the South? After the Civil War, the real promise America made to African Americans was, one of the promises was 40 acres in a mule, and they actually meant that literally. And then the US didn't really follow through on that at all. But Black Americans took up the challenge of acquiring land in earnest. And by 1920, there were a million Black farm families in this country,
法院还表示，“征服者的法庭决定了征服的边界”。是的，所以这就是（你知道的），强权即公理的潜在现实永远是所有权的基石。我也对你们在书中讨论的关于所有权如何影响美国黑人财富的话题着迷。能给我讲讲南方黑人土地所有者面临的一些问题吗？内战结束后，美国对非裔美国人真正的承诺之一，其中一个承诺就是“四十亩土地和一头骡子”，而且他们当时真的是字面意思上这么想的。然后美国根本没有真正兑现这个承诺。但美国黑人真心实意地接受了获取土地的挑战。到1920年，这个国家有一百万黑人农民家庭，
substantial amount of southern land was owned by black farmers. In the last 100 years, since 1920, black farm land ownership is dropped by about 98%. There are fewer than 20,000 black farm families left in America today. A lot of the reason for that is racist violence and racial discrimination, particularly in farm lending. That's a big part of the story. But there's another part of the story that really hasn't been told very much. And it's an artifact of ownership rules.
南方相当大一部分土地由黑人农民拥有。在过去的100年里，自1920年以来，黑人农地所有权下降了大约98%。今天在美国，剩下的黑人农民家庭不到2万个。造成这种情况的很大一部分原因是种族暴力和种族歧视，特别是在农业贷款方面。这是故事很大的一部分。但还有另一部分故事其实并没有被讲得太多。它是所有权规则的一个产物。
So if you die without a will, and black farmers usually did, you'll land a split among your kids, might be three kids or four kids or five. And if they die without a will, it's split in other ways. So one farm, 100 acres, might have three and 5 and 9 and 30 and then hundreds over the years of partial owners. They turned a little fraction of the farm. And it turns out that American law makes it virtually impossible for those farms, farms that are owned by a big group of errors to be managed at all. And white lawyers figured this out in the south, that they could buy a 1-100th or 1-1000th
所以如果你在没有遗嘱的情况下去世，而黑人农民通常都是这样，你的土地就会在你的孩子之间分割，可能是三个孩子、四个孩子或五个孩子。如果他们在没有遗嘱的情况下去世，又会以其他方式分割。因此，一个100英亩的农场，可能在多年里会有3个、5个、9个、30个甚至数百个共有产权人。他们拥有农场的一小部分。结果证明，美国的法律使得这些由大群继承人拥有的农场几乎根本无法管理。南方的白人工人发现了这一点，他们可以买下那个农场1/100或1/1000的
share of that farm. They could buy out for 100 bucks. They'd find some air in Chicago and say, I want to take that 1-1000th share that you have. It turns out under American law, with that 1-1000th share, you can force on the courthouse steps a sale of the farm as a whole. It was a cash sale. I meant that the Black Farm family that owned it had been in their family for generations, lost their farms on these so-called partition sales when they were sold on the courthouse steps for trivial amounts to the white lawyers who had gone north and bought these very small shares.
份额。他们可以用100美元买断。他们会在芝加哥找到某个继承人，然后说：我想买下你拥有的那1/1000的份额。事实证明，根据美国法律，凭借那1/1000的份额，你可以在法院台阶上强行将整个农场进行拍卖。这是一场现金拍卖。这意味着原本属于黑人农民家庭、已经在他们家族中传承了几代人的农场，在这些所谓的分割拍卖中失去了，因为它们在法院台阶上被以微不足道的金额卖给了那些去到北方并买下了这些极小份额的白人律师。
So that sort of hidden rule of American ownership, sort of the intersection of how you own property together and what happens if you don't make a will, has led to just devastating wealth destruction for black farm families in this country. It's quite easy to fix. Number of European countries have rules that make it actually quite easy for those co-owners, all the grandkids and great-grandkids, to actually manage the farm effectively, to be able to get mortgage, just be able to improve the farm. But American law doesn't really allow for that.
因此，美国所有权这种隐藏的规则——也就是你如何共同拥有财产以及如果你没有立遗嘱会发生什么情况的交叉点——给这个国家的黑人农民家庭带来了毁灭性的财富破坏。这其实很容易解决。许多欧洲国家都有这样的规则：使得这些共有产权人（所有的孙辈和曾孙辈）能够非常容易地实际管理农场，能够获得抵押贷款，从而能够改善农场。但美国法律实际上并不允许这样做。
And it's been one of the great engines of wealth destruction for African Americans over the last century. What's clear is that ownership is not a fixed thing. It's not cut and dry. It's always something that's negotiated over time. So if I were to take your book, knowing all the things I know from it, and I'm on an airplane, and someone leans back, how should I take the knowledge from your book and turn it into a practical lesson in that moment? Well, for every story in the book, there's different ways you can respond. You can respond as a consumer and as a citizen.
这成为了过去一个世纪里导致非裔美国人财富毁灭的巨大引擎之一。很明显，所有权不是一成不变的东西。它不是非黑即白的。它始终是一个随着时间推移不断谈判的过程。所以，如果我带着从你们书里学到的所有知识，坐在飞机上，有人把椅背往后调了，我该如何将你们书中的知识转化为那一刻的实用课程呢？好吧，对于书中的每一个故事，你都可以做出不同的反应。你可以作为一个消费者和一个公民做出反应。
So let me tell you first how you respond as a consumer. The event study's done about this. The person in back who's squished turns out to often be the academic researcher. And what they've discovered is that there are ways to solve this problem just as the person who wants to keep their laptop, not totally in their face. And here's what you do. This is actually news you can use for your listeners. It turns out that if you offer them 20 bucks,
所以让我先告诉你如何作为一个消费者做出反应。对此进行过事件研究。坐在后面被挤压的人往往是学术研究人员。而他们发现的是，有一些方法可以解决这个问题，就像那个想要保留笔记本电脑、不想让它完全贴在脸上的乘客一样。这就是你的做法。这其实是对你们听众有用的实用资讯。事实证明，如果你给他们20美元，
person in front typically won't take it. And if you just ask them how to lean back, they look at you funny. But there is something that does work. So it turns out that if you offer to buy the person in front of you a drink or a snack, three quarters of the time, they'll accept it and they won't lean back. Turns out that people like to feel like they're in
前面的人通常不会接受。而如果你只是要求他们把椅背调回去，他们会觉得你很搞笑。但确实有一种方法是奏效的。事实证明，如果你主动提出给坐在你前面的那个人买一杯饮料或一份零食，四分之三的情况下，他们会接受，而且他们不会把椅背往后调。事实证明，人们喜欢那种身处
community. They want to feel like they're good guys. And the way to sort of engender that feeling is to offer them a drink or a snack. So that's how you solve the problem of the person leaning into your lap as a consumer. There's also an answer as a citizen, which is that we're getting mad at each other as that space shrinks. We can take the story of ownership and we can say the airlines are using this tool of strategic ambiguity and we can lobby, we can lobby to change the rules. In 2018, the FAA decided that airline seat design was going to be left totally to the airlines.
集体中的感觉。他们想觉得自己是好人。而激发出这种感觉的方法就是请他们喝一杯饮料或吃一份零食。这就是你作为消费者解决前面的人侵入你膝盖前空间的方法。作为一个公民也有一个答案，那就是随着那个空间的缩小，我们开始对彼此感到愤怒。我们可以拿所有权的故事说事，我们可以说航空公司正在使用这种战略模糊性的工具，我们可以进行游说，游说改变规则。2018年，美国联邦航空管理局（FAA）决定将飞机座椅的设计完全留给航空公司决定。
But that's just a choice. And it's a choice that can change. And if there are enough fist fights, if there's enough pressure by consumers who are pissed off, then the rules will change. There's no fixed rule for who owns what, Who owns that wedge of space up in the air? That's great. I love the idea of us locking arms and just we just blame their lines. I mean that's true that I mean because they're fall We should play the robots It's not the friendly skies
但这只是一种选择。这是一种可以改变的选择。如果有足够多的拳脚相加，如果有足够多被激怒的消费者施加压力，那么规则就会改变。对于谁拥有什么并没有固定规则，谁拥有空中那片狭小的空间？这太棒了。我喜欢我们大家携手并肩，然后把责任全推给航空公司的想法。我的意思是这确实是真的，因为这是他们的错。我们应该把责任推给机器人。这可不是什么友好的天空。
The book is so fascinating. I had such a good time reading it. Thank you so much for talking with me. Pleasure to be here. This is really fun. And as a long time super fan of your show, this is a real treat. Jim Sultzman and Michael Heller are the authors of the book Mine. How the hidden rules of ownership control our lives. It is a very fun book to read and to argue about. You can enjoy it. We're off next week for a short summer break, Celebration July 4th, but we will return with new episodes on July 13th.
这本书太迷人了。我读得非常开心。非常感谢您与我交谈。很高兴来到这里。这真的很有趣。作为你节目的长期超级粉丝，这真是一次绝佳的体验。吉姆·萨尔茨曼和迈克尔·海勒是《所有权：所有权的隐藏规则如何控制我们的生活》一书的作者。这是一本非常有趣且引人争论的书。你会喜欢的。我们下周将休假一周，进行简短的夏季休息，庆祝7月4日，但我们将在7月13日带着新节目回归。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube. Music and Sound Max by a director of Sound, Sean Riel. Our executive producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colestetti is the digital director, the rest of the team, includes Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, and Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemma Dawn, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family. Now headquartered at 6 blocks north, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me out Roman Mars on the show at 9-9-PI-ORG, we're on Instagram and read it too.
本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作。音乐和音效由声音总监肖恩·里尔负责。我们的执行制片人是德兰妮·霍尔，库尔特·科莱斯蒂蒂是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括薇薇安·莱、乔·罗森伯格、安·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢玛·唐、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher & Serious XM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区北部6个街区。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。您可以在推特上关注我罗曼·马尔斯，节目账号是 9-9-PI-ORG，我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。
You can find other shows I love from Stitcher and every past episode of 99PI at 9-9-PI-ORG. Excuse me, hi, Sean Rial here. This got me thinking. This episode is kind of mine. I mean, I mixed it, so I'm the last hand on it, and possession is in fact 9th tense of the law. So I think what this means is I get to do the stitcher tag. Well here we go. Stitcher! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在 9-9-PI-ORG 上找到我喜欢的来自 Stitcher 的其他节目以及 99PI 的每一期过往节目。不好意思，嗨，我是肖恩·里尔。这让我想到了这一点。这一集某种程度上属于我。我的意思是，我混音的，所以我是最后经手的人，而且占有确实占了法律的十分之九。所以我想这意味着我可以做 Stitcher 标签了。好吧，我们开始吧。Stitcher！本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。